ام سائد تحاول ترتيب منزلها وافكارها معا
عقب ليله لم تكن هادئه حيث تعرض منزل
العائله في مخيم عقبه جبر لاقتحام الجيش
الاسرائيلي باعداد كبيره كسر الباب مباشره
ودخلوا الجيش فكان مجندات في جنود فاتوا
على البيت بلشوا تكسير وتخريب وما خلوا
ولا شغله بالبيت اللي فتحوها وشافوها
والاواعي كلهم
وجابوا الكلب ويشمشم كل شيء بالبيت
واستمرت العمليه لمده ساعتين بالضبط وبعد
ما خلصوا تفتيش وكل شيء
اخذوا ابني كان موجود اعتقلوه اخذوه
كلبشوه واخذوا معاهم
مئات الجنود وعشرات الاليات حاصرت المخيم
عند منتصف الليل
واقتحمت اكثر من 30 منزلا فيما اصيب
العشرات من الفلسطينيين بالرصاص والاختناق
بحسب الفلسطينيين فان العمليه التي نفذها
الجيش الاسرائيلي هنا في مخيم عقبه جبر
قرب اريحا هي الاضخم منذ سنوات
رافقتها عمليات اقتحام للجيش الاسرائيلي
نفذها في عدد من مدن الضفه الغربيه اضافه
الى هجمات المستوطنين على منازل وممتلكات
الفلسطينيين تحديدا شمال الاراضي
الفلسطينيه عشرات المستوطنين برفقه الجيش
الاسرائيلي هاجموا منازل الفلسطينيين في
قريه برقه شمال الاراضي الفلسطينيه
واحرقوا مزرعه وعشرات اشجار الزيتون فيما
اعتقل الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من عشرين
فلسطينيا من مناطق متفرقه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه من مخيم عقبه جبر كور باريحا
خالد القاسم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات